après ce week end en tête à tête lucas
till finalement réussi à faire des
milliers la femme de sa vie
ça dégage la comédie la you to want a
souhaité aujourd'hui retrouvent pour la
suite dit billy the way avons nous
réussi à sortir avec ml durant ce
superbe week-end en amoureux
j'ai dit qu'on arrêtait la comédie est
ce qu'au bout de trois ans on a enfin
réussir à sortir avec cette fille on n'a
jamais vu ça jamais un homme n'a attendu
aussi longtemps pour une fille c'est
parti nous sommes prêts et je sais que
ça fait un moment depuis la dernière
fois qu'on s'est parlé je met peu
importe où et m'a dit un truc que j'ai
pas compris donc je vais dire est ce que
tout va bien
ouais tout va bien bon ça nous agace ça
veut dire que tout va pas bien wake août
j'espère est qu'on puisse parler hockey
si tu veux ça ils vont parler de ce qui
s'est passé ce week-end là j'ai juste
l'impression que les choses sont bizarre
entre nous est-ce que tu te sens pareil
je vais dire que oui je me sens pareil
mais le sait pas de quoi il s'agit on
ampute un caniche me dis pas que tu as
fait n'importe quoi le week-end je pense
que c'est à cause de l'année dernière
les choses sont devenus bizarres depuis
que je t'ai rendu visite
tout doux s'il te plaît soit honnête
avec moi est ce que tu avais l'intention
qui se passe quelque chose entre nous
battant mais pas du tout ma vie dit par
année d'alcool et je t'ai je tenais je
touchais pas fait venir dans ma chance
je devais venir autour du campus pour
course est clair qu'on fasse des trucs
sont là en compte d'autres sommes quand
même à tanger tegra frau quoi j'étais
petit j'étais trop à faire bloquer non
mais va se calmer celle là haut je suis
dès que j'ai été trop mignon je vais
dire non je vais nié les faits non mais
c'est vrai je voulais juste la voir
bordel après des années non mais c'est
vrai on peut voir une amie tu t'investis
à la poème dit ok mais juste au cas où
j'ai eu l'impression que tout était
planifié je veux dire on est sorti avec
tes amis autour du campus et ensuite on
est retourné dans sa chambre pour pour y
passer la nuit tu devais savoir à quel
point j'étais vulnérable mais jeu mais
[ __ ] mais j'ai rien fait mais il lui
fait pas du direct de devenir dans la
chambre un an elle me prend la tête de
fous je dire je ne savais pas je ne
savais pas tu avais l'air bien je sais
pas mais c'est vrai il arrête tu voulais
me voir pour aller mieux et [ __ ] je
suis en mode victime quoi j'ai vraiment
l'impression de dette autres me faire
planter un couteau dans le coeur ok je
juge je sais pas est-ce que tu regrettes
tu es venu me voir
est-ce que tu as passé un mauvais moment
mais ce que j'ai fait quelque chose de
mal parce l'on posé trois questions d'un
coup comme ça on sera vraiment fixé
jeudi à celui fait quelque chose de mal
non tu as un fait de mal bon ben voilà
bah alors juste beaucoup de choses sont
arrivés très rapidement ça m'a fait
juste me sentir différentes dans un
mauvais sens je vais dire non pas dans
un mauvais sens juste différente je sais
pas tu as la même à temps mais ce qui me
dit c'est pas clair du tout quoi soit
clair ce que tu t'es ville il se plaît
j'ai demandé sera toujours pareil entre
nous en aller en train de mâcher en en
hockey catastrophe catastrophe plan
catastrophe j'ai dit et suite force que
ce sera plus jamais parler entre nous
elle m'a dit je ne sais vraiment pas je
suis désolé mais les choses deviennent
vraiment bizarre pour moi maintenant
mais merci de m'avoir parlé tout ça et
je peux répondre ouais ok pas de souci
on peut parler quand tu veux je vais
dire on peut parler continue
je te plait pas ta [ __ ] elle son patin
[ __ ] ok c'est bon elle décide de
continuer de parler elle me dit comment
ça se passe à l'école et tout le reste
vous dire que c'est une union comme ça
elle va comprendre que j'ai de wendel
elle me demande comment va mal tu mon
ami à toi le pétomane quoi là haut je me
dire il va bien c'est pas vraiment mon
ami à juillet ses parents mon ami m
répond ouais ça fait chier quand les
gens changent et à propos de tout notre
amie emma veut dire je n'ai pas vu
depuis un moment elle me demande c'est
juste une amie ou oui c'est juste une
amie angie au hockey c'est toi tu joues
emilie pourquoi tu comprends pas ça je
suis désolé je pense que je ne veux pas
faire ça maintenant faire quoi est ce
que quelque chose va mal ou what do you
mean qu'est ce que tu veux dire oh what
do you wanna know
emily diehl ou jeu devenant dont elle
est en train de lâcher ce n'est aussi
diverses et affolent heavily m'occupe
pas l'ensemble maintenant c'est très
difficile toute façon je vais devoir y
aller mais on se parlera plus tard
ouais bien sûr à tout site et pas la
dernière année c'est impossible aux
justin bieber tel choix
justin bieber chalet temps vouloir
chapitre 5 ces derniers chapitres on en
2006 ça fait cinq ans mon gars hockey me
elard je mettrais y ait oud ou chez m
what's up train spécial nba me demande
comment je vais je veux dire tout va
bien elle me dit oh cool
[ __ ] la discussion commence trop mal
quoi je vais demander comment est-ce que
les choses se passent trop elle elle me
dit que tout se passe très bien
[ __ ] mais développe arrête de faire
des pauses ferber je veux encore plus ça
on à revoir andy ram spécial c'est ma
dernière année d'école au je sais pas si
tu savais mais moi et brad on s'est
remis ensemble
super je vais dire good for you et jade
goody parlions good for you owe email
comment va ton amie emma d'accord il y
avait vraiment calé avec ma peau thema
pourrait débarrasser de moi bon bah
c'est le morceau excuse mais il dit pas
très bien elle a commencé à ressortir
avec mike donc maintenant j'aimerais
plus au nom même du bon toute façon le
collège s'est quasiment fini je lui
dirai ce que ça te manquera m dit ouais
je suppose mais je suis content que ce
soit terminé je suis juste fatigué de me
rappeler certaines choses
ok ok qu'est ce que tu fais cet été
voilà excellent attend me dis pas
qu'elle part en vacances avec brad j'ai
juste traîner ici avec brad essayer de
trouver un job au commenta semaine s'est
passé elle s'est bien passé j'étais très
occupé qu'est ce que tu fais à l'heure
où on parle elle fait c'est de voir
comment ça se passe à l'école elle fait
que des aides pour ce camp mais mon gars
c'est un truc de ouf
déjà depuis thaler dont les frasiak
goodbye à chaque fois donc je pense que
ça va mal finir j'ai demandé si elle
allait à certains concerts dernièrement
et c'est dû parler des groupes qu'elle
aime la [ __ ] s'accroche aux branches
non je suis trop occupé avec l'école de
réponse goodbye n'en est ce que c'est ça
qui nous
attends à nokia ok en fait à chaque fois
il veut parler en mode c'est la fin et
trouvent un moyen de parler alors
qu'elle lui répond froidement quoi à ce
qu'il était c'est nul quel temps il fait
là où tu es un scénic va bien au non non
c'est la folle vie et me disent oui m il
est parti goodbye
ok je pense que je vais aller au revoir
m répond quoi au revoir
ok bail oh là là là là mais non même la
caméra la variété de films elle était
sous le choc émotionnel [ __ ] et midi
nous a vraiment bâché totalement c'est
dingue comme j'ai pas si ce soir là sous
les étoiles par exemple il l'avait
embrassé comme ans aurait changé toutes
leurs destinées c'est plein de petites
choses comme ça aussi c'était passé ça
tellement mans et bien derrière il
serait passé sa fin c'est c'est le
destin c'est bon t'as exécute se tourner
autour comme des tourtereaux et le jour
où il se voit
après coup emilienne fait une phase
bizarre genre a finalement je préférais
quand on était amis friends au revoir à
je suis dégoûté iam social i'm in don't
forget to like this video if you like
dit watson ne vous a plu [ __ ] c'était
un super jeu très très original et puis
acteur sous très haute dans une
prochaine vidéo on va tous rêver des
milliers ce soir et munich est loin qui
ne veut plus de nous à travers le monde